ok this is a Diamond digger saga points
levels tutorial there's different types
of levels and Dominator Sawyer points
are the simplest they start at the
beginning that being said there are
several hardpoints levels later in the
game just real quick we'll go over the
different icons we have points levels
just have gems in the bubble fireflies
levels have a little Firefly there and
toys levels have a rubber duck and when
we go up later into the game there's one
more it starts at level 71 and that is
the totems levels so you don't have to
worry about those until later but we're
just going to talk about how these
levels work and some tips on how to play
them the the goal is to reach 18,000
points so we'll go ahead and click Play
and wait till the board loads and then
you'll see that there's some blocks that
have the gold ribbons those those
contain treasures one of the things that
when you first learn how to play you
think all i got to collect all these
because that's where going to get my
points but in reality and a lot of
levels the the actual the actual
treasures in the first couple of rooms
are worth very few points like i'll just
I wouldn't normally click this to waste
a movie i'll just show you real quick
see that's only worth 100 points so
you're never going to get to 18,000 by
collecting other point matches so in
these cases what you want to do is try
to make it to the treasure room as fast
as you can so we're going to go ahead
and do that we need to leave the water
leave the water from the top to the
bottom these ground blocks in the middle
are they take two matches to get through
because they have the cracked stone on
top and then we have a couple ground
blocks that are
used up the block your progress and they
kind of get porous as you hit them so
right now they're they take two hits but
when you make a match next to them then
they'll they'll go to the water they'll
be removed so this is a little helpful
thing that you'll get in some levels
it's a rocket and when you match it with
diamonds at the same color then you can
shoot it off another player slow path
and so now we just have to clear out
this space so that we can get the water
here to the exit we already have our
pink match ready for that so we won't
you won't mess with that until we get to
water down alright so we didn't really
get a quick way to do it but we'll just
keep plugging all
you see we were chipping away at those
blocks the forest one now since there's
no Cascades and Diamond digger one of
the things you need to try to do is plan
things out as they fall because none of
these diamonds are going to disappear
until you click on them and in this case
here everything's blocked we have a lot
of different colors and play so it's
it's not making it easy on it so I'm
going to go ahead and clear the door
first to see how it falls and it fell to
give us the mash everyone so we can
answer the room we only got 500 points
but as mentioned you don't really need
to worry too much about that because
what we're trying to do is make it to
the treasure room and in the treasure
room the there are large gems and
they're worth 2,000 each when you match
them so just going to work our way down
you can't quite get the water out yet so
we're going to go ahead and work on
these ground box and since they're lower
we're hoping with something old become
available above and did so now we got
the water to the exit and we can move on
and you can see these these are what a
little bit more than worth 500 but still
not worth going out of your way for so
there's no match that's really well this
one will start the water because we do
that first and then we'll work towards
the eggs or two and see wait to see if
we get a match set up at the top this
rocket will help in this case it will
take out that row and our rechargeables
boost is charged up but we don't need to
use that yet we can get out for that
third runs a little bit more complicated
so that's why it's nice to keep your
boost ready and our rockets are set up
pretty good so I'm going to go ahead and
fire that one on and they're missing
wrong and now we're close to exit in the
room we got some things blocking our way
but I go ahead and open the door first
now I'm going to use my color boost who
is going to clear out a bunch of the
middle and now we have a match that will
get us out and that will bring us to the
treasure room treasure room like I said
is most most cases that's where you want
to go to get all your points together
each of these large gems are worth 2,000
this isn't this one has three different
colors so it's not like you're going to
get a ton but we have 12 moves and we
have to clear three of them or we have
to clear six of them to get our target
goal so we're pretty we're pretty set up
here to do that and so you can see like
if we came here with less move because
we were trying to pick up 100 or 500
point treasures it would make getting
our goal a lot more difficult and there
we have it so when you're playing a
points level something to keep in mind
is how much the treasures are worth in
the early rooms if it's a tough level
you're going to deplane it more than one
so always to keep track of how much they
you know how much they're worth if
they're not worth 2,000 that's the
highest it can be then they're really
not worth going after your waist removes
all the treasure rooms are different
some only have two colors so you can get
a ton of points in them some of them
have
and I guess there's probably something
that might even have more and those ones
are going to be a little bit more
difficult so as a general rule when
you're on points level you're having
trouble you want to get to the end as
fast as you can but if there's some of
them you don't have to make it to the to
the treasure room either you can get
into a room that has much twelve two
thousand point treasures and collect
your points there so that's pretty much
the ins and outs it's the simplest level
requirement but we want to make a video
to just explain it if you have any
questions leave comment if you found the
video useful or helpful please look like
it and feel free to leave those
questions or comments either on youtube
on our facebook group or on our website
itself Diamond digger saga tips com
thanks